hello my name is Caleb Denby and welcome
back to game review hoo-uh
alright everybody today we're gonna be
going over a game between Hikaru
Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen Magnus with
the white pieces in this case from the
accessible Masters Tournament that chest
24 is hosting and this has truly been a
really unique and interesting tournament
thus far as of recording day they have
just I believe finished the preliminary
stage where they had a group a and a
group B that each played a round robin
or maybe a double round-robin with each
other and the top four from each group
of six managed to advance to the
playoffs stages and it was pretty
interesting actually in group a we had
Magnus Carlsen hakuro Nakamura a few
other very notable names and then a
group B we essentially had the
candidates roster six players all from
the candidates so it's really unique to
see these two groups and how these
players are interacting in this game of
course we had Magnus against akaru
so in this game of course we had Magnus
playing one d4 Karo Knight f6 c4 e6
Knight f3 avoiding any potential names
of Indians with Knight c3 this is kind
of the popular move order these days
from the grandmasters turns out they've
decided there's not so much to be gained
by playing Knight c3 first that it's
worth risking the nimzo-indian stead
Knight c3 Bishop e7 Bishop f4 and
castles and this is a line that karo has
actually been repeating more or less in
every game that he's gotten in the
Queen's Gambit he plays the same qgd
line and has been daring his opponents
to prove that white can try for an
advantage here now pretty much everybody
and the grandmother has been playing III
in this position Hikaru has been playing
knight bt7 rather than c5 here and this
allows white to play this move
c5 and so players with the white pieces
have really been attempting to prove an
advantage here against Accardo with this
far
see pond you end up in a position that
is super super closed with at least one
or two files being opened on the
queenside
at a later date sort of at blacks
discretion really it's black deciding
when to open these files and players
have had mixed results against a car Oh
some have managed to wing car has
managed to hold a lot of games but that
is not what we got in this game
magnets had actually come up with a new
idea here in the form of a three now
there are three moves highlighted on the
board these are the three main responses
to a three now a three of course is
definitely a very serious sideline just
for reference in my database here there
are 72 hundred games that went white
applying III only 300 with white playing
a three so it's a move but not a very
common move and so more often than not
players have played b6 they've played c5
challenging the center and they've
played D takes e4 now in my opinion I do
think a move like c5 is probably
objectively the best move here and in
fact the Cardo has actually played
multiple games in this exact variation
with c5 and I think he's won quite a
number of them with black actually and
the reason I think c5 is just
objectively the best move is because
without playing III and playing a move
like a three instead white is very
seriously claiming he wants to play the
move b4 at a later date and he's kind of
doing it at any cost
now of course a3 is a much less good
developing move for white which mean
white which means white is going to be a
little bit behind in this battle for the
center here
so because a3 doesn't develop doesn't
control the center it's blacks time to
strike in the center with the move c5
now in this game
hikaru instead decided to repeat what
he's been doing with the move Knight B
to d7 now I do actually think this is
sort of what Magnus was hoping for an IP
to d7 is the fourth most popular move
and I believe it's not the most popular
because it does allow White's next move
Magnus in this game plays the move
Knight b5 and I think this was sort of
the point of Magnussen's play
and this is the danger when you're a
top-level grandmaster and you're
repeating the same line game after game
after game you're going to run in to
some pretty interesting novelties are
ideas or even if they're not novelties
sidelines that you absolutely must be
prepared for if you're going to repeat
the same thing every game you're
allowing your opponent's to sort of take
their best shot at you every time they
get this position because they know
they're going to get this position in
this case I'm not so sure
her car was as well prepared as he
thought he was there's only really one
move here for black you can't play
something like c6 you're just asking for
Knight c7 to happen to you with disaster
striking thereafter with this rekon be
eight hanging although actually this
would not be the line hold on
c6 Bishop c7 would be the issue of
course in the 96 sorry I forgot that
this work was actually defended but 96
and then this trick does get trapped on
f8 my apologies okay so c6 not playable
that means the only real choice here is
98 just defending this C pawn and 98 is
understandably a little bit awkward for
black not his most comfortable move here
now the move III does come on the board
for Magnus and he sort of achieved
everything he wants to achieve out of
this opening you know he's got this
bishop opened up he's defending his C
pawn for the moment moves like c5 are
pretty well under control because these
Knights are just a little bit too
awkward for black to handle he's gonna
have issues on the d5 square because
this Knight is in the way of its own
queen in the actual game hakuro started
with d takes c4 and this is very much
not my my favorite move by akaru likely
what happened is he wanted to play the
move c5 but the issue here as stated is
that this Knight is just a little bit in
the way and this would run into C takes
d5
he takes d5 and then I move like Knight
c3 I move like D takes c5 when this epon
or a deep on rather is going to be a
little bit weak in the long run I think
something like 93 even immediately and
this iqp is not going to be so
comfortable because 98 is very much not
a useful move
these positions so to try to avoid that
Hikaru actually takes on c4 the issue
with this of course is that white is
usually happy to play these positions
after having wasted a tempo with Bishop
d3 followed by Bishop takes c4 in this
case Magnus definitely gets an edge over
these positions by taking with c4 taking
on c4 and one fell swoop without moving
the bishop first now Acharya tries for
some very concrete play playing c5
immediately to try and clarify the
structure in the center and sort of
equalize in this manner and the issue
with this is my feeling of these
positions has always been if white can
get c5 in and managed to contest these
files and develop his pieces then by all
means he is going to be absolutely equal
with no problems in these positions the
issue arises when black can usually get
D 5 D takes c4 and c5 in all at once but
white can sometimes still have an
advantage in these positions if his
pieces are significantly more active
than blacks and that is exactly the case
in in this specific scenario here it's
true that black gets to clarify these
structures but it's going to struggle
significantly to get the activity that
white is enjoying currently in the game
Magnus takes on c5 and Hikaru actually
inserts an intermezzo here with the move
a six sort of removing these threats of
ninety six of nine c7 immediately you
don't want to play a move like ninety
six immediately here you're gonna run
into the move Knight takes e5 sort of
kicking the legs out from underneath
this Knight and now you have nothing
better than to start trading and these
trades are actually just going to be
beneficial for black letting him
activate his pieces
so rather than ninety six the world
champion shows Knight B to d4 and we
actually saw Bishop takes e5 rather than
Knight takes e5 from Hikaru and this is
a move that sort of supplies surprised
me at first glance at first glance you
really would think you want to take this
pawn with the knight this is sort of why
Accardo is playing Knight bd7 before
playing c5 taking what the knight is
slightly more comfortable in this case
though maybe
was concerned a move about a move such
as b4 here when all of a sudden this
night does get to e4 but the point of
whites a3 is sort of shining through now
with this extra queenside space on the
board in the game Bishop takes c5 and
now if white continued would be for
there's actually a pretty interesting
option here of playing the
strange-looking move Knight b6 as in
tournament Intermezzo countering the
threat to blacks bishop with a with an
attack on White's I don't know if this
is what Hikaru had in mind but it's
definitely a potential option here just
an example line Bishop d3 now Bishop d6
is an extra option for black to
immediately trade off these bishops and
like I said trades in this case
definitely advantageous for black in
order to untangle those pieces anyways
we did see Bishop takes c5 King side
castles from Magnus and now Queenie 7 by
akaru and so far the caro is doing a
pretty good job of sort of maintaining
the balance here I do think White has a
little bit of an edge in this case just
because black still has many many
problems to solve with where his pieces
are currently standing in the game
Magnus played the move rook c1 which is
by no means a bad move but it does allow
the karu sort of a chance to make a very
serious claim in the center here in this
specific position the car is sort of
only chance to try and equalize is going
to be this move e5 c5 challenging
White's strong actively placed pieces in
in the center now it's understandable
why chicory who didn't want to play this
move and that's because it does open up
there's some very powerful LightSquared
bishop this this bishop now has access
to the King more directly to these to
this f7 pawn it also allows moves like
you know at first glance and a 5 might
be good it turns out it's it's not so
good because Knight a5
of Queen f6 is simply winning but Bishop
g5 is a very understandable move and now
black sort of has to pin himself with
Nate D to f6
pawn to f6 is of course an illegal move
in this case and now after a move like
Knight back to e2 hikaru is definitely
going to be looking to play a move like
bish
six in the near future I can't do it now
because of the awkwardness with this
Bishop but if black does manage to
achieve Bishop to e6 trading off these
guys then he's well on his way to two
equalizing in this game if I've not
played in the game though Bishop d6
immediately was Magnus through Hikaru's
choice and now simply Bishop a2 is
Magnus Carlson's idea here he just drops
this bishop back and says okay you know
I definitely have control of these two
files why don't I start exerting that
pressure on your position Knight d2 f6
was still Hikaru's choice without you
five inserted and now the move ninety
five comes on the board and you sort of
realized well hey I miss my chance to
play e5 and now after 95 by white it's
sort of never going to happen and this
Bishop is going to suffer for a long
long long time Knight back to d7 was
actually a car's response to this sort
of admitting his mistake perhaps saying
I do need control of this v square and
now it does allow Magnus Carlsen to play
a very serious tactic here so if you're
watching at home go ahead pause the
video try to find this tactic for
yourself it's a very very fun one okay
hopefully you've got it of course that
tactic is Knight takes up no just
kidding Knight takes f7 does win but the
move plate in the game is even stronger
Knight d2 c6
this is sort of a zinger against a card
Nakamura highlighting the fact that
these pieces are far too awkward to stay
safe on this open D file of course if
you capture this night we will take back
with the night hitting the Queen the
Queen will have to move and then we can
regain our piece on the d6 square and
not only are we regaining the piece but
we are creating some very serious
threats of winning even more material
and these threats I simply think cannot
be parried for example if you just move
the king out of the way
well good luck ever untangling these
pieces this rook can't move this Bishop
can't move this R it could come to eat
eight but it doesn't really do anything
if you try and move like just for
example e5 here you're gonna get them
out with Queen to c7 and you have all
the same issues this works coming in and
this is just simply devastating for
black car of course knows this so he
tries to not capture this knight on c6
going for Queen h4 instead but now
Magnus plays very very simply Bishop g3
hitting the Queen Queen g5 h for hitting
the Queen again Queen f6 Knight g4
hitting the Queen again no safe squares
for this Queen the Queen now comes all
the way to be to Magnus inserts Bishop
takes d6 hitting this rook no time to
capture on c6 as or no time to capture
on a 2 as the move 97 check would come
in with takes on c8 and takes on f8 no
time to take on c6 as the move rook c2
first and then takes on f8 but that is
actually what we saw in the game B takes
c6 rook see to this Queen has to move
Queen b5 Bishop takes f8 and now Magnus
is just up a winning amount of material
here he throw in the move h5 sort of
tempting black into capturing an age 5
when this Queen would just invade very
concretely to the d8 square but in the
game
h6 was a car's choice now Queen f3 on
the board by Magnus car does decide to
capture this pawn on h5
but now Queen takes c6 is simply a a
winning move here night c7 played in the
game Queen back to f3 Magnus Carlsen
choice now Knight up to d5 we got G 4G v
by Hikaru and then this next move forced
resignation by Hikaru simply Knight
takes h6 some sort of funny tactics in
between moves at the end but the result
was never really in doubt from this from
the moment this Knight d2 c6 move kind
of occurred on the board Magnus kept a
winning advantage throughout of course
the game could have continued Queen
takes h6 Bishop takes d5 and these are
two threats that cannot be parried at
the same time so Magnus Carlsen winning
a very convincing game here against a
Caro and I'll be interested to see how a
car responds to this line if it is
played against him again of course I do
think there are much better choices for
black than the line that cards show
and I definitely would expect him to be
switching lines to something else
against this move a three that's all for
today on game review thank you so much
for joining me
my name is Caleb Denby and I will see
you next time